la kinder fetta al latte miracolo della
modernità ciao ragazzi e bentornato in
una puntata di cucina buttata oggi una
puntata all'insegna di esperimenti
questo qui è uno degli snack se non lo
snack preferito il mio fratello gabriele
insieme alla kinder pinguì ea kinder
delice in realtà io preferisco la fiesta
non so quante persone preferiscono la
fiesta e la di liszt
c'è qualcuno che ancora mangia la de lys
dalla fiesta imbarazzante silenzio anzi
precisa avere questo ottobre la nostra
preferita detto ciò oggi faremo quella
cosa che ogni bambino sogna una kinder
dicevo una kinder fetta al latte gigante
il web è pieno zeppo pieno zeppo di
persone che ripropongono la di inter
fetta al latte gigante quindi ci siamo
detti che siamo noi per non provare a
fare la stessa cosa visto che la nostra
personalità monta 0 ecco perché fra le
varie ricette che ci ha convinto di più
è la ricetta di saporito punto it che vi
riproporremo a brevissimo per fare
l'inter fetta al latte avremo bisogno di
tre uova 125 g di farina 40 grammi di
cacao parla al 20 per cento di grassi
125 g di zucchero 5 grammi di lievito in
polvere ragazzi questi erano gli
ingredienti per l'impasto passiamo
adesso a quelli della farcitura 500
grammi di mascarpone 200 millilitri di
panna al cim quando 30 per cento di
grassi 100 grammi di zucchero a velo e
70 grammi di miele
per prima cosa mettiamo lettere uova
all'interno di terina
non ho fatto
oh yeah
pensiamo 125 grammi mazza quanto non 128
no pensiamo 125 g di zucchero vi giuro
che non c'è un altro numero e gli
aggiungiamo alle uova fruste alla mano
quando fate queste cose non abbiate
paura di perdere un po di tempo
con questi prodotti è più il risultato
migliore guardate buon cristiano adesso
io adoro quando succede questa cosa
pazzesca è molto più chiara aggiungiamo
a questo punto 125 millilitri di panna
quel 20 per cento
125 g di panna anzi millilitri scusate
siamo lì dentro e montiamo di nuovo il
momento serio ho scoperto che in questo
modo riesco andare molto più veloce
dobbiamo nessuno dietro di loro tutti
quanti gli ingredienti secchi in farina
cacao e lievito vi faccio vedere una
faccio io metto una terrina sopra
bilancia faccio la tara da questa volta
giunta la farina al 125,2 niente
rifaccio la tara e al suo punto sempre a
dentro ci metto 40 grammi di cacao
bellissimo di nuovo la tara 5 grammi di
lievito di e senza sporcare niente e con
una frusta una spatola di mettete a
mischiare mentre fissate lo schermo nero
del vostro computer
a questo punto uniamo indiretti secchi a
quelli liquidi e arredi niamo l'entrata
buttare ormai si sta a casa
ma perché hai voluto usare quello perché
sembra più figo ma lei usa un cucchiaio
c'è una cosa che a me non interessa
quello che fanno gli altri non faccio
tutto quello che fanno gli altri siti
nicolari buttarti alla cresta di butera
finestra il solito anarchico si è capito
e concorre ricordarti che senza di voi
sono venute tutte bene le cose
vendi l'anarchia fa bene cucina se viene
sempre il vostro cuore
mai le ricette infatti sono tornato
giusto giusto per questa torta lo sa far
vedere la meraviglia di questi pastori
guarda eccezionale ign ora c'è la parte
divertente
bisogna standard
però non è venuto benissimo chi mi provo
si può forti e adesso diarrea shah khan
accada a caracalla
li vediamo il livello bile come di
pittori musica
[Musica]
la molta soddisfazione vedere questo
provvedimento è vero ma è anche farlo in
realtà sembra tipo di essere entrato di
nuovo il signor calvagno il nostro
muratore anche non me ne voglia sapere
punto it e noi l'ho fatta più sottile
perché la loro e che può un mattone e
quindi sto cercato di invece di fare una
cosa che di proporzioni un pochino più
simile a senso junmin secondo me sì
molto senso perfetto a questo punto
inforniamo in forno preriscaldato a 180
gradi per 10 15 minuti ci staro attento
non voglio che faccia la stessa fine del
pane del cus avrebbe preso da cucina io
sentivo puzza di bruciato lui
passiamo alla crema 500 grammi di
mascarpone la soddisfazione cro
nell'usare il mascarpone dolci
non so perché ma scusate rumori che
mascarpone una tazza del cesso bucata e
non avevi voglia di qatar a 70 grammi di
miele
mi raccomando ragazzi andiamo molto
molto cauti perché poi non so come
togliere il miele se sbagli la
proporzione
ma allora non c'è un jack l'odore buono
aspetto anche a me sembra fatto questo
qui zitto
questo qui non mettano da parte e
lasciamo che si raffreddi importante se
non è carino che finiamo la crema e poi
sforniamo lo lasciamo raffreddare e alla
fine dopo che si sarà raffreddato
vediamo tutto e henri miniamo la scarpa
è bello coriaceo in alternativa se non
volete usare il mascarpone volete fare
un qualcosa di leggero potete utilizzare
niente nulla ma temi vanno farvelo
mangiatevi dell'area e vede le nostre
lacrime mamma mia
marco io giuro io giuro che se viene qua
che torni in fase 1
metti piede proprio in questa abitazione
mai più fino al 2022
ok l'ho detto e adesso montiamo la panna
panna al 30 per cento di grassi 200
millilitri carta
quale erano totalmente sbagliati i
valori delle pagine con cap cioè non
abbiamo per poter fare anche i piccoli
chimici all'interno di questa cucina
cura più magra una più grassa poi andate
con dio ragazzi 200 metri e palla ho
dimenticato di pesare lo zucchero non
capisco questa tua reazione di panico
voce tranquilla no io ho sempre volesse
smorti a vanna maranese smontano le
parti quando cucina insieme a te ma
ancora né montava kit e smonta non puoi
smontare una cosa che non è montata su
100 beh silene autostima
il max vanta zucchero il rumore dei
denti mamma mia zucchero e montiamo di
nuovo la finiamo diventare l'uomo un
pargolo zucchero
ti amo sia non fare la panna con lo
zucchero a velo pd a zurigo lo zucchero
ad hoc
ci tenevo a precisare che questa cucina
non per renderlo noto è innamorata
pazzesco non l'ho mai visto così seconda
risposta
mia madre è venuta qui nei compensi
ormai per cagare vado fuori perché ho
paura toccare accesso a questo punto mi
amò panna al composto se ancora andando
benissimo ma nessun intoppo
l'unica cosa che mi sento di fare è
adesso infilarlo un secondo in frigo per
rapprendersi in modo che quando andremo
a spalmare rimane bella solida invece
che è arrivato adesso il momento
dell'assembramento prendiamo un coltello
per favore a meta precisa è di elmo
giammarco to watching sta portando una
sfiga ma una stima totale tutto a posto
che è successo veramente non nutre
simpatia per me io non posso fare io ho
avuto la simpatia tua come cugino ma non
come presenza di terrore
la cucina fuori dalla mia cucina
bello bello il fichissimo senti
prendiamo la panna e andiamo a farcirlo
perché dobbiamo comunque creare il
kinder fettone all'atto né e poi
metterlo in freezer per mettere i minuti
ma da forno e rassodare per bene e poi
le paragoniamo esatto ecco io in dubbio
guarda perché sta colando che bella tu
hai l'aria negativa nonino questa
negatività
ha ragione dietro scuse c'è qualcosa che
non mi torna
oddio un po liquidi ma forse della crema
con le guide ma secondo me piano con le
parole io c'era svengono spariamo che
con molta dignità anche se vuoi labor di
meglio dire ma come hai fatto un bagno e
burger
non lo so c'è qualcosa che non mi sta
quadrando mettevano se non è fredda
raggiungerà lo spiaccicato linzalone
tronto il ghiaccio o su uno stock
assetto cioè un altro non è se non è
completamente rotto avendo il carrubo
aspettiamo la recchia le minori perché
tu non l'hai non è fatto la rifinitura e
che la faccia quando è bella solo ci
vediamo tra venti minuti sono passati 30
minuti io sento un'aria frizzante e
marco non so te io sono tranquillissimo
a carico non bellissimo da vedere la
faccio un lavoro di riferimento ok in
meno male che da veri fatta finale ma le
posso dire che non è terribile terribile
da vedere
credo perché non metteresti più piede
qua dentro e non c'è la crema signori
nel frattempo i segreti da questo canale
metteteci un pollice in su per il e
scrivete nei vostri commenti un insulto
per gianmarco maltrattati la crema che
solo da me va bene è colpa mia quando
assaggiarla andiamo fuori
vogliamo fare quel una lavatrice in
funzione di sottofondo ma perché perché
ci manca che notate ragazzi lo sfondo
abbiamo creato questa è una grande fetta
al latte reale catalano vantano valori
non traguardo tagliato un pezzo di
caracas
prenditi le misure sta sputando crema
ovunque
venti le vicine quello che lo mangi del
palazzo ottima
tra marco e gianmarco guarda non
possiamo fare disastro sei tu che stai
precedenti disastro non possiamo fare un
disastro proviamo passaggio una più una
vera ma anche io farò questo questo
testo buona norma signor kinder è stato
bravissimo
vai vai vai vai vai vai a fregiarsi a
litio merito dopo un po la kinder
paradiso bersani non si trovi pochi
ingredienti che ci sono dentro perché è
partito da fare dai ma scusa ma cazzo
mette sei mangiato tra diventare
all'originale io ho fatto una promessa
durante questo video cavo io non c'entro
niente sei l'unico che voleva televita
cui ho riportato il format antico
splendore si è licenziato ragazzi ci
vediamo martedì